we're officially live with episode
number 102 with the toms
zenner ellsworth and kai
and we got a lot of topics to get into
today
uh i think just uh okay because of what
youtube announced i think we should test
this out because this may be the last
time we can press the dislike button so
folks just to test it out why don't you
press that dislike button see how we can
confuse the algorithms today because
apparently
did you hear the explanation the guy
made on behalf of youtube when they said
why they're getting rid of the dislike
button have you heard that whole
conversation harassment you know so have
you have you guys been following that
story at all or not what do you what do
you think about this whole dislike
button being gone trying to i think it's
good to be honest with you really you
think it's good no i do and i'll tell
you why because i've
come on am i not allowed in the middle
of the pbd podcast
not today no i like it because those
mobs out there exist you know they're
going to gang up on some of these
smaller content creators and hammer them
right into oblivion oh my god what the
hell is wrong with that man
i don't like it you could tell tom
started making youtube content listen
let me ask you a question let me ask you
a question if you like the fact that
they're getting rid of the dislike
button give it a thumbs up if you hate
the fact that they're getting rid of the
dislike button give it a thumbs down i'm
actually really curious to know what the
audience is going to say
uh yeah look at that i mean people do
not like this anyways we got a lot of
stories we'll get into that so i am in
the minority here you are in the very
minorities here yeah i'm a minority
you're living in california that's a big
minority here this is texas florida
florida california yeah uh which by the
way was in california just a couple of
days ago what do you think celebrating
george palaho's wedding in daniela which
was fantastic had a great time great but
while i was there we went to uh uh
crustaceans restaurant nice yeah so we
go to crustaceans and now we walk in and
uh the hostess says uh
says uh uh sir if you want to eat over
here we need your vaccination card i
said you know i don't like to carry my
passport with me so they said well you
can't eat inside you know if you don't
have your passport you got to eat
outside so it's okay we'll eat outside
so we sit outside and we eat crustaceans
outside food is good you own you know
order garlic noodles whatever they got
so ten minutes later i have to use the
restroom so i pulled the waiter i said
listen i got a question for you says
what's that i said since i don't have my
vaccination card and i can't use the
restroom outside do i just pee on the
sidewalk what do i do says no no sir
please don't do that you can use the
restroom i said so what do you mean i
can't go inside what are the criteria
the guy finally says honestly sir we're
just trying to figure this thing out we
have no clue what to do we just don't
want to get fined i said listen i
respect i'm just giving you a hard time
plus they have plenty of people peeing
on the sidewalk outside right you would
look like one of 600 000 people that are
currently
every day you can set up your tent
afterwards
republicans call them the homeless the
democrats call them voters but anyway
they're all they're out in the sidewalk
getting it done he said hey would you
please homeless democrats call them
borders exactly right hey what'd you
think what would you take away didn't
you love wearing a mask everywhere well
i i gotta tell you a few things number
one we stayed at the uh uh the four
seasons beverly hills right across from
rodeo and they were pretty chill about
the mass nobody was like put it on
because i never put it on so i'm just
testing to see if someone's going to
come and be a mass cop no one bothered
me at all okay no one bothered me i ran
into pj tucker i said pj let me tell you
something here says i just found out you
got traded away from the box i said i
don't think the bucks can win without
you i can't believe they traded you to
miami he was cracking up anyways but no
one bothered you with the mask
uh we went out and uh you know we went
to different places nobody was bothering
us with your mask a lot so it was pretty
chill and i didn't see as many homeless
people as i did six months ago eight
months ago they're cleaning it up a
little bit i think they're maybe because
we were in beverly hills half the time
so you're not going to see a lot of
homes plus the super bowl's coming in a
couple months they've got to start
cleaning they've got it up yeah so good
glad you had fun yeah we did okay all
right so let's go through this year we
got some stories big short michael bury
has some problems with ilama selling the
stock we'll talk about that bitcoin
creator satoshi nakamoto may have to
unmask at a florida trial apparently
this guy would be one of the top 20
richest people in the world worth
74 billion dollars a little over a
million bitcoins that he has himself uh
nbc's reveals the dirty little secret
that people can actually afford
inflation we'll definitely talk about
that when your rent goes up 40 as
pandemic fades many tenants see big
hikes youtube hiding the dislike button
disney employees beginning to relocate
from california florida because it is
more business friendly climate obama's
economist larry summers slams biting on
inflation saying it doesn't look so
transitory economist larry summers says
white house misread inflation nearly
half of democrats won a candidate other
than biden to run in 2024 howard stern
just made a bold prediction about donald
trump 2024 run folks this one's funny we
got to cover that one biden and kamala
relationship is in crisis as her poll
ratings crash just one year in andrew
cuomo considering running for attorney
general of new york beto says he'll
change greg abbott and he'll challenge
great gap in the race for texas governor
2022 dea this is probably one of the
most important stories therefore pay pay
very close attention to this because you
do not want to offend people
dea stop saying mexico cartel to appease
mexico recently retired agency official
says they want to live
across racial lines policy policing
emerged as the deciding factor in
elections and iran back militants storm
us embassy in yemen seized hostages and
equipment so let's first talk about the
youtube hiding the dislike button okay
page number four if you want to go to it
um so youtube is hiding this line counts
in an effort to protect content creators
from harassment or nbc story
they're making some changes to its
platform in an effort to protect
creators by hiding this line counts on
videos on wednesday the video sharing
service began rolling out a new feature
that keeps the accounts private and only
viewable to the person who uploaded the
video the actual dislike button however
will remain and viewers can still
dislike a video to tune their personal
recommendations but only the talent sees
it the update feature was sparked by an
experiment youtube conducted earlier
this year to see whether changes by to
the dislike button could help protect
content creators and harassment dislike
attacks where viewers purposely dislike
a video to drive up the content so now
here's a funny thing that people need to
know about the dislike button do you
know you know this i'm not going to ask
him let's see what tom and tom are going
to say do you know what is the most
disliked video of all time on youtube
something with cats do you know what it
is i'm actually being serious david do
you know you may know it do you know
what the most disliked video of all time
is on youtube i know the most lacked the
most liked oh yeah i do i do
it's a youtube video it's a youtube
rewind video
yeah so go back tyler go on youtube type
in youtube rewind 2018.
so so the the the person that was
representing youtube when they made this
video oh my god look at that tyler
you are making kai look good 2018 2018.
eight maybe it's the keyboard there's
four check that out
don't press on it go to youtube.com go
to youtube.com instead of going that way
yeah just go to youtube.com
uh click on it you're good okay so on
youtube right there right rewind 2018
rewind 2018 check this out
rewind oh man we cannot press it right
so just click on it and press pause
immediately press pause immediately
pause pause pause okay good so check
this out three million likes 19 million
dislikes and the video to introduce the
dislike button
got 14 000 likes and 147 000 dislikes
people don't like this a lot of people
are saying it's political some are
saying it's youtube some are saying it's
offending people it's hurting people's
feelings i know you think this is a good
idea i do i don't here's the thing i
don't think it's a horrible idea okay
i'm not sure if it's a good idea i don't
think it's a bad idea maybe you guys
will convince me by the way some people
agree with you they say facebook only
has a like button that doesn't have a
dislike button so some people are saying
it from that end don't act like it won't
sway some people when their initial
impression is this video sucks right so
i i don't understand the downside to it
because if you're really interested as a
content creator how many people don't
like your videos you're still going to
know you're going to still have access
to that data are you open to be
convinced like to be to change your mind
no i you i have the most open mind okay
so let me have alex do you ever go
when you go to restaurants do you want
to know what review they get on on yelp
um because i'm going to send you some
browsers only the good ones only the
good okay now that's a good question
okay um you and sean that's friday night
shonda says babe let's go to a new
restaurant what do you guys do i'm not
the guy that goes to yelp i pretty much
know the people that own the restaurant
i'm just kidding some of us are not
celebrities but i'm talking about no uh
dude yes i i will as a blanket statement
i will trust some of the reviews okay as
a as i will as well act right okay so
let me ask you this question now this
one you're gonna change a little bit do
you do you look do you judge movies
based on rotten tomatoes
no okay i agree so for me i'm the same i
don't agree with some rotten tomatoes
but i do follow yelp right
videos when it's disliked
for me it does a couple different things
as a viewer it gives me like i sit down
it's like i don't know if i want to
watch this or not you know you got seven
different videos you search and you look
it's like this guy because sometimes
what happens with videos people put a
title
that doesn't it's a click bait and then
you go spend four minutes and they never
explain the video and it's [ __ ] but
if i would have seen the dislike like
ratio and it shows 88 likes and 700
dislikes he's not going to answer the
question because other people got upset
about it as well so i think the dislike
button helps you save time that's my
opinion if you assume that they're doing
it for the right reasons and i guess my
reason for thinking that i'm against it
or i think it's a good idea not to have
the dislike button is because there are
those groups that go out there and
sabotage
tallies so two sides to it i get both i
think i think there's one aspect that i
can kind of support or understand why
they're doing it uh caleb mentioned in
the chat here and i talked to me
yesterday about it but the last two
years they haven't been like it hasn't
changed the seo on videos so it's not an
indicator of how many like dislikes you
get in the back of the day you used to
kill a video now it doesn't so if it has
a lot of dislikes it's whatever so at
that point the button doesn't really
indicate anything or
improve on the seo so for then for that
matter it's just there to kind of show
it so that aspect of it is kind of
useless at that point
i think there's two things here uh and
the first thing is
why is google doing this they want to
prevent dislike attacks reviewers you
know
team up and you get this this onslaught
of people that just want to attack a
video
well there's two things going on first
of all tic tocs pan for creators and
tick tock is moving and so youtube has
got to protect its content first and
what it's really saying is that we don't
know how to stop the dislike attacks the
way the dislike attacks are stopped on
yelp glass door you know google reviews
is you have to log in so they want to
make sure that you're a real person
you've logged in you've confirmed the
account so you can't just have a bunch
of anonymous people on yelp destroy a
restaurant it doesn't work or open table
so there's the mechanism that they have
there gotta have an account or you can't
slam it whereas what google is saying
gosh if these dislike attacks happen
there's perfectly good content creators
that are getting hurt here and we're
also at a point where
youtube is starting to increasingly try
to figure out with shorts and things
like that how do i compete with tik tok
so i think there's a bigger thing
that's that's underneath here where
google is saying how do i stop dislike
attacks that are
seemingly
kind of you know anonymous so that i can
have some integrity to the count because
i do want to know if i go on yelp and i
can't see the negatives 300 positive for
a restaurant does not mean there's not
301 negative i'm like well that's very
neutral because that restaurant could
have been in there for five years and so
the numbers if you suppress it yeah it's
very deceptive i there's a part of that
that you
make sense on what you're saying with a
like dislike but
i just don't know the more i think about
it you know i want to be able to see
both sides i want to see the like and a
dislike for whatever for many different
reasons uh you know somebody made a very
very good point here they they
speculated that the reason why they took
the dislike button off is because of
adam because you know adam doesn't like
the dislike button i will tell you by
the way if why people are saying if adam
is fired or not adam is at another
convention
this is this is not a cat convention
adam is in dallas again by the way
i don't know maybe he's not in dallas
he's somewhere else he's not at a cat
convention uh it's a different
convention he's at he doesn't want me to
reveal it what convention it is it's
very private maybe when he comes back
he'll tell us what the convention is i
mean i know what it is but i don't guess
i don't know if he publicly wants people
to know what convention it is so we're
going to build that little bit up it's
the men against dogs foundation see i
don't want to say that you you took it
out and he texted him yeah i didn't want
to say it but it is
mad here's here's what i will tell you
here's what i will tell you the one part
that i fully understand so last night
two nights ago two nights ago i'm
talking to tikkun dylan okay
it's sunday night
i go upstairs and
talking to tikkon dylan and dylan's got
a voice
i really like it when dylan sings but
didn't doesn't want to hear me when he
sings he likes to sing by himself
and he was singing the other day this
song hallelujah
hallelujah that whole song right he's
singing it and i'm listening to him so i
go to the room i put cinna down and i go
to tikko and then i said tiko dylan
why don't you why don't you want to sing
i don't want to sing daddy i said why
don't i get you this singing coach and
you work with them one-on-one no
why not i have stage fright
i said dylan what do you mean what you
have stage right he says there's such a
thing called stage fright that i said
there's no such a thing as stage fright
he says dad i'm telling you there's such
a thing as stage fright i said who tells
you there's such a thing as stage pride
he says daddy there is stage fright then
tico chimes and tiko's like he's right
there is such a terrifying according to
statistics there is that let me teach
you stage fright is people who get on
stage and they're afraid when people
look at him i said tico whoever tells
you they're stage fright they're lying
to you
but daddy i read it in a book that books
i'm telling you anyways long story short
we're talking to these kids
and i'm sitting going back and forth
with them i said dylan let me ask you a
question i said what's your favorite
song so he says hallelujah by pen what
is penitent penta how do you pronounce
it
pentatonix am i saying it correctly or
no pentatonic something like that is
that the right way to say the band's
name pentatonix i said okay let's listen
to it i pull up the video i said how
many views do you think this thing's got
640 million views hallelujah pretty
crazy by the way number like that i said
how many likes you think it's got
he says uh i don't know i said six
million likes he says six million likes
i said how many people you think gave it
a thumbs up okay thumbs down this is the
part where youtube makes sense he says
74 people so he thinks only
this is the innocence of a kid because
he thinks how are you not going to like
a great song like this and i pull up the
number the number is and seventy four
thousand people put a thumbs up i tell
tikkun dylan 174 000. this is their
reaction
why would so many people not like it i
don't understand i said tico dylan
here's what you got to understand no
matter what you do you're not going to
please everybody right there's going to
be a lot of people that are not going to
like you so here's a challenge with this
this is the problem i have with this
i've had multiple people that had their
shows on youtube when they came on
valuetainment you know what's the first
thing i tell them don't read the
comments
and if you read the comments don't take
them personal you're a new talent
they're not used to you yet be patient
but i know
how hard is it for new talent to see the
commentary that's negative and you build
that up so for new talent you know dylan
just taught you know the whole thing
with stage fright and the fear so i can
see how that can kind of backfire but it
is what it is i'd like to see the thumbs
down uh stay here but here's one thing i
don't think it's accurate data right i
think it could be skewed so much so i
don't think there's that many benefits
from the thumbs up or thumbs down
question are they going to keep it as it
is right now will that be locked where
you'll see where it is stuck in time
x or are they going to eliminate it all
together creators going to see it but
the person viewing it's not going to see
it yeah the creator okay we'll see it
but i want i want to see that but at
that point they should also delete the
remove the likes so you can't publicly
see how many likes there are because the
big thing is also seeing how long has
the video been out what is the ratio and
then seeing okay it seems to be good it
seems to be not so good so if you're
removing one why not just remove the
other and then let the creators see on
the back end can i tell you when we did
this story on vt post last week and i
was thinking about this a little bit and
i have a new philosophy in general i'm
gonna [ __ ] less about big tech
companies unless it really is affecting
my life like a thumbs up or a thumbs
down like this doesn't affect my life
the benefits that the tech companies
bring to me
are so strong that i'm going to hold off
unless they're listening to everything i
say and somebody coming knocking on my
door right
so
what you're saying is you're planning on
running for office in california you'd
like their support and an exercise i'm
starting to sound like that i like it
three million donations the reality of
it is we need rejections we need to get
our skin to be thicker and this is
making people softer and i don't support
it for that specific reason anyways it
is what it is we'll continue let's go to
the next door next story
is uh a
bitcoin creator satoshi nakamoto could
be unmasked at florida trial so
a lot of people are talking about the
specifically the cryptocurrency
community
um so uh uh the family of a deceased man
is suing his former business partner
over control of their partnerships
assets in this case the asset in
question
uh are a cachet of about 1 million
bitcoins equivalent to about 64 to 70
billion today belonging to bitcoin's
creator and pseudonym satoshi nakamoto
the family of the dead man says he and
his business partner together were
nakamoto and thus the family is entitled
to half the fortune this is what a
florida jury will try to tackle the
family of david kleinman is suing his
former business partner 52 year old 51
year old australian programmer living in
london named craig wright wright has
been arguing since 2016 that he created
a bitcoin claim dismissed by most in
bitcoin community climbing's family
argues that the two worked on and mine
bitcoin together entitled climbing
family to a half a million bitcoins by
the way very interesting angle to get
satoshi to come out right i actually
like the angle to force the guy to come
out
you know this story is really
fascinating and you know there's so much
money involved i'm surprised somebody
has been killed yet right because this
goes back to 2008
somebody is holding on to that private
key right someone has it you're thinking
maybe they're not coming out for that
reason you think that's why the person
doesn't want others to know i think this
thing could be a movie it could be a
deadline episode or a dateline episode
or something now i do know the one
person on the planet that could find the
true identity here we go of sakamoto no
komodo sakamoto yeah that's a that's a
drink but it's bernie sanders because
he'll want that tax money right so he
can go find that person go get the tax
money out he can shame him on twitter
aoc on the case right i believe that he
could actually find it but this really
is a fascinating story who leaves that
much money out there unless they're very
very patient right and and this whole
thing with a florida only in florida
right could you find this it's one of
those only in florida um it seems like a
stretch but the deep this this is a fast
if they had core tv i'd be watching this
trial on tv right now i really would
so i think nothing's gonna happen i
don't think i mean you interviewed craig
wright do you think he's satoshi
nakamoto i don't know i i i lean towards
no but i don't know but i i there's a
lot of people in the community there's
some that say craig wright there's a lot
that say adam back there's a lot you
know there's different names that come
up on who could be satoshi nakamoto i
know who robert in the office thinks it
is cia he thinks it's the city he thinks
it's the government that's behind it the
government designed this is what he's
thinking
and the other thing i think as well with
this is robert a big thing a big thing
yeah we went to the moon in 1920
gentlemen so
it's uh it's it's robert and that's a
that's a bright guy to say something
like that it's not like robert's not a
bright guy no no not at all not at all
uh the only the big thing here for me is
that the
neither one of them have found have the
keys to the to the to the wallet so
without that you're screwed the private
key yes and without that you can't even
get a hold exactly so so why would if
you're if if craig wright is him and he
claims to be him why wouldn't he just
reveal it it's like one thing you have
to do to prove it well bbc did a story
with him i think it was bbc did a story
with him getting him ready to reveal the
key and he was supposed and he couldn't
do it i don't know if you've seen the
video i haven't seen that video it's if
you've not seen it it's very interesting
like it's still i'm gonna show the world
that i'm the guy and it's like oh it's
not working i forgot i you know so it's
kind of a little bit awkward exactly if
you listen to this folks who do you
think especially those you guys that
follow crypto who do you think satoshi
nakamoto is go ahead tom
you know
i think things hide in plain sight and
no one has come out to counter these
guys
and so as odd as it sounds and the
missing key
sometimes the simplest explanations like
when big complicated crimes you have all
the talking heads talking about crimes
for weeks and weeks and weeks like the
missing girl and then the guy
found in the swamp right it ends up
being very simple it's always that guy
you know nobody beyonce
it's a simpler story than we all
weave it into being while we're
overthinking it i
i tend to lean that it's these guys
these guys are in a partnership and they
create it because it's usually the
simple answer so you do think this is
the i'm leaning this way i'm leaning
this way saying you know what this is
very plausible these two guys created it
these two guys created the the the you
know the the the secret pirate in the
back you know flying the flag against
fiat currency and you know okay question
for you what's what's their rationale
for not cashing in on any of it
tom he's asking yes a question
it's i you know i can't that's that's
the part in this case i can't get my
head around it's like why why wouldn't
one of them take the money and run i
mean in this case though if they were
partners and craig wright proved to have
it then he'd have to pay look there's
very interesting things with law you
sent me a story yesterday about vanessa
bryan but what happened where she was
maybe you tell the story what happened
there well she's suing la county
sheriff's department because they took
photos of the of the crash scene when
kobe died they looked at him they
circulated them she's suing them saying
that it has caused her some serious
traumatic damage right so now the county
wants access to her records of any
psychological exams or therapy sessions
so they can see if it actually did cause
that or if she's just saying that so
that's what you're saying so so that's
the part about law
that if you file a lawsuit
the person can come and ask specific
questions to validate your point that it
affected you right and in this case
when this guy's coming out saying
satoshi is my 50 50 partner
if he doesn't come out i mean law law
could almost force the sky to come out
so he's either going to be sitting there
saying look you know i don't want to
come out and give up half of 74 billion
or he's going to come out and say it's
me
and then
how is this going to change adam back
said in an interview
about
why it's not a good idea for satoshi to
come out and why it's better for the
world not to know yeah the way he
explained it was it's better to not see
the one person as an expert because
every time something happens with that
currency they're going to go to so what
do you think since you started this what
do you think since you started says i
don't think that's a good idea i think
we need to leave it alone
as just a currency without a founder to
that currency that's their view on
bitcoin i think a big thing about that
too is that it's better to not have
somebody who's behind it because then
it's truly decentralized like if it's if
it's a certain person then that's his
argument you don't know how much he owns
and if that could then totally tank the
market or not so i think a big thing
there is just a matter of having it
decentralized to where we don't know and
that's part of the mystery of which is a
good thing because that gives it a
little bit trust it's more like almost
spiritual or religious where it's like
i believe in it i don't know who what
why but that's kind of what we're
thinking i was interviewed by natalie
brunell yesterday who's a a bitcoin
expert and a finance expert kind of like
a pompliano type of person not crypto
she made it very specific she's bitcoin
uh and she's uh uh
what do you call it a finance expert
and she had a story that went live on
twitter uh that went viral on twitter
like a million views or two million
views on fox business she was talking on
how the economy right now is favoring
bitcoin you saw what shamath said just a
couple days ago the fact that
people were laughing at me when bitcoin
was 200 and i told them this thing's
going to go to the roof and you guys
didn't buy into it and now it's 60 some
thousand dollars it's going to go to 100
000. it's going to go to 150. it's going
to go to 200 000 it's a matter of time
before that happens it's going to happen
in a year two years three years i don't
know
but the argument of where they are is
making more and more and more sense
on the ethereum side what's starting to
make more sense is the fact that all
nfts are being purchased through
ethereum which means those who were not
for ethereum if nft takes off that means
ethereum takes off so the biggest
question right now
for an investor if i were to ask a
question and i you know
both sides of the argument they give me
different arguments here's here's the
argument what's ethereum today what is
the word today do you know what the
numbers are now or not theory i was just
popping that up i lifted my pronouns
what is ethereum right now i go over to
coinbase and see the uh the stock uh uh
it's at four thousand three hundred and
eighteen dollars okay so ethereum is at
forty three eighteen okay and bitcoin is
at sixty thousand seven thirty two right
here's the question you gotta ask
yourself what is more likely of
happening is it more likely for ethereum
to go from 4 300 to 12 000 or is it more
likely for bitcoin to go from 60 000 to
200 000 what's more likely can i say
they're equally likely exactly right
okay you're saying equal yeah so that's
what the bitcoin folks will say that
it's equally likely likely but the nft
folks will tell you ethereum's going to
catch up to bitcoin that's the debate
right now between the two yeah this is
the law of small stocks right you come
into a stock at five you think you go to
15. now you just tripled your money
whereas you go into you know amazon or
apple at 250 it's got to get to 600. so
it's you know it's the law of small
stocks here it's a really good point
there because you've got you know
wearable and open c really controlling
like 80 percent of the nft market or
something like that i mean they are the
giants in the room
and it's all ethereum and you know with
um
[Music]
and what's the leading mask the uh the
leading wallet mask okay so check this
out we got 324 likes right now and we
got 95 dislikes folks if you're more
leaning towards bitcoin
tripling before ethereum put thumbs up
if you're more for ethereum tripling
before bitcoin put thumbs down i'm
curious because i the it is becoming
like a religion it's so interesting
watching the bitcoin and the ethereum
community can i say something about this
story i think it is utterly fascinating
that we don't know the creator of
bitcoin because if you are involved in
that world where you are creating a
currency you're in the finance world
you're interested in making money all
right you're driven by that and this is
just sitting here no one knows either
the person's dead right or
what could possibly be the motivation
for us not knowing who this is and what
happens when this is 740 billion or a
200 billion or something like that it's
74 billion right now if we were talking
about this story at the beginning of the
year it would have been way less than
that but that's a lot of money sitting
on the table that's not going to be the
first lawsuit and i just think this is a
fascinating mystery so you think it's a
matter of time it's a matter of time
before it comes out
i think maybe
that maybe not so much the identity of a
single person but maybe more of how this
was created and then we'll learn that it
isn't one person possibly
by the way it's it's more people voting
for bitcoin tripling than ethereum yeah
two to one is what the numbers are
looking like right now so there's a lot
of bitcoin people than ethereum people
specific maybe at least that on this
podcast uh real diaz thank you for the
20 bucks somebody that just gave 50
uh said the following which is quite
interesting he said convince the
government created bitcoin perfect tool
for moving off the books cache also
guaranteed to have built in
totally disagree with that totally
disagree tell me why because it's too
hard for a government employee to keep a
secret i i could see a no it's not it's
not a government employer though this is
like a a
yeah but a government employee would
know of the secret no
somehow if you go if you go from the
defense budget where
i mean they can't even keep track of
their money they don't know what goes
where and who has what and who has
access to what and who knows about what
so if anything in the government it's
some sort of military budget that's been
off the books blacklisted that where
it's been and then there's a i mean look
they're looking to change the military
some former military member that was
involved at this would talk i think when
you create something that potentially
becomes this big enough people know
about it where someone is going to say
something if it's a government entity
okay let's go to the next story when
your rent goes up 40 it's on page three
if you want to go there so this is a
cnbc story when your rent goes up 40 as
pandemic fades
many tenants see big hikes
as a purely discounted rents in cities
comes to an end many tenants are bracing
for steep increases that could force
them to leave their homes as cities
begin to begin to resemble their
pre-cove itself again and the period of
discounted rents evaporates many tenants
are facing a similarly unpleasant
reversal renters who originally received
pandemic pricing are now experiencing
steep rent increases at renewal uh
sometimes upwards of 40 so for example
if you're paying four thousand dollars a
month it's gonna go to 56 that's a real
number by the way if you're paying two
grand it's gonna go to twenty eight
hundred that eight hundred dollars a car
payment and a cell phone bill and maybe
insurance yep uh so said aliyah mohamed
of open
igloo which allows renters in new york
uh city to review landlords i'm amazed
this is legal
while it's true that most tenants in the
u.s aren't protected by rent control
policies some are meanwhile others are
held by requirements they may be given
certain amount orders that was only
running
all right so forty percent tom what do
you think is going to happen here
i think rents are going up baby because
then i'll give you two reasons for is it
inevitable i think it's inevitable
because percent inevitable
i don't think now 40 i think is a good
headline it's a big spike it's going up
if you you listen to the average joe
it's up 15 it's up 20 you're seeing
multiple markets people talking about it
and there's there's a couple issues
going on here number one
we are so fortunate that most of the u.s
counties because counties control the
property taxes not the states individual
counties
you do not raise the taxes on a
mark-to-market basis each year they
incrementally raise them it's like a
small raise on it but when you commit a
transaction
then that's a new superstep
in the property tax and what you've got
here is people are buying
rental homes highly leveraged highly
leveraged and so soon as we get interest
rates rising on those underlying
mortgages under the rental house that's
pushing it up and inflation in general
is pushing it up and i think the average
consumer that's renting is is going to
get jammed by this this is just the tip
of the iceberg 40 big headline story but
this is happening okay kai what do you
think uh i mean this is the craziest
number for me is the from 57 in the
second quarter to 74 and third i mean
that's uh what do you mean what do you
mean by that 57-74 attracting qualified
people um he said the
percentage of firms difficult attracting
qualified
uh well i'm on the wrong story what am i
doing here okay
no no the biggest thing biggest thing
for me is in terms of that um i spoke to
sam and for us the place we stayed would
would go up 400 bucks for next year
where you're at right now yeah per month
per month no total for the whole year
okay so the whole rent would go up 400
uh and
zero ver 400 per month no 400 total i
believe per year yes what are you
talking about no it's not no no no per
month per month yeah the monthly basis
so that's five grand a year yeah that
adds up you know when when the whole
rent forgiveness thing was happening
yeah couldn't you see this thing is
where was this gonna end that lasted for
over a year and you know there was a lot
of landlords that took it in the shorts
in in a huge way but they were talking
about mass
evictions and how i mean if you have any
common sense you would think that would
have to happen so what are the numbers
apparently evictions are up 12 in
september and they're up 25 in october
over august so they're happening but one
of the reasons they're not super
terrible is they had all that federal
money available right that they had a
lot of rental assistance money and i
guess some of that is getting used now i
think i saw where 10 billion is now
being used by about 2 million renters
that have access to it but to use that
money you need the landlord to
participate in that program with you and
i can imagine so many landlords are
ticked off that these renters did not
pay for a year or a year longer longer
than a year and many could and
definitely could and they want them out
regardless right so they're not going to
participate and try to get these federal
funds they're going to get somebody get
them out of there bring somebody in
there they can raise the rent a little
bit so i think this is just the
beginning of this because there are real
life consequences to not paying your
rent for a year right and rolling the
dice and taking that gamble but here's
the thing so this leads me to the story
of labor shortage okay this is a cnn
story if the labor shortage continues
the u.s economy won't be able to recover
after enhanced unemployment benefits
expired and schools reopened in person
many expected workers to go back to work
in nation's labor shortage to ease
significantly by september but recent
data suggests if anything the shortage
is getting more severe a majority of
smaller firms 51 percent say that they
have job openings they are unable to
fill the ceo confidence survey revealed
that the percentage of firms
citing difficulty attracting qualified
people jumped from 57
in q2 of 2021 to
for the first time in decades the
scenario of wage price will spiral where
higher price and rising wages feed each
other by the way you know what the
numbers of how many people are fewer
employed today than it was two years ago
you know the number millions what is the
numbers working workforce yes i'm gonna
say 12 million seven million fewer today
that are not even going back by the way
seven million no interest and and the
seven million people that we're talking
about they're not buying cars they're
going to their jobs one small thing
happens they just say i don't want to
work i go home
and they're not feeling like there's any
major urgency to want to work there is
zero urgency right now to go back to
work seven million that's not a few
that's a lot of people right there we
just we just bought a building right
this one building that we bought and
we're sitting down with the designer
and the designer comes in and the
architect that's it so how long is it
gonna take to get the permits he says
that's not a problem you're going to get
four to six weeks i said okay great how
long is it going to take for us to get
you know the demo and all the stuff on
the inside he says we'll get a gc we'll
get that done within four to six months
okay fine sounds good weeks six six 46
no no to six months the gc that is four
it's not weeks four to six months also
demo and build what you desire yes four
to six months that's it so what's the
biggest challenge he says you ready i
said yes he says do you want glass doors
and glass windows in your office i said
of course he says six to 12 months i
said get out of here says yeah he says
are you buying new furniture or are you
bringing furniture i said no it's going
to be a new furniture because it's a new
look with the designer he says 6 to 12
months i said are you kidding me he says
labor shortage and supply is adding up
we can't get people to work and we can't
get supplies today
people are being affected by this you
saw the other car company what is the
car company tyler i don't know if we
have that as one the series or not gm gm
is talking about the fact that
the chips are what but i know was
general motors reveals heated seat
option
due to chip shortage they're removing it
what do you mean you're removing it so
the labor shortage the chips this is
being affected in many different
industries yeah you know what i read a
really interesting study preparing for
this story and it came out from the
american institute of economic research
i don't know if they have any political
leanings whatsoever but they said that
this labor shortage is not a surprise to
the government in fact they call it
mandated and subsidized mandated
mandated because of the coveted
shutdowns right you shut down the
economy this is what's going to happen
and they knew it subsidized means all
the free money that they're giving out
so what they're basically saying is the
people that are making these decisions
are are anti-capitalists and it's a fact
and you can look at the data because the
markets correct themselves they have a
way of correcting themselves when it
comes to the labor pool right enough
people will go out there but it's not
like these people have permanently
pulled themselves out of the workforce
they don't want to go back because they
don't have to go back the job is there
you know what they've learned here's
what they've learned in the last year
they don't want to go back to that same
job at the same pay because they know
they can get more or they can make more
doing nothing so the government knows
exactly this is economics 101 for
governments and politicians and they
know about this and this is happening
because they wanted to simple question
for you the seven million people that
are not voting today okay
let's just play a simple game do you
think these seven million people what
percentage of them do you think are
going to vote for more you know benefits
more money to be sent out free money are
they going to vote left or what
percentage of 7 million is going to vote
right they're going to vote 90 percent
for where they can keep the gravy train
cut what do you think
out of the 7 million what do you think
include our friend sami 1 000
they're going to vote for
to stay home and not do much so so the
seven million who are not wanting to go
back they're gonna vote for more more of
the same good stimulus checks to be sent
out to them okay then if that's the case
if we're talking purely strategically
it's working great strategy for the
people on the left it's very strategic
because you got seven million more votes
you've got votes and you're a solid
number by the way if you think about it
yeah i feel a little differently i think
you get a dive into these numbers a
little bit because i i read that there
was two and a half million
older people that were in you know
moderately
moderately priced jobs is you don't earn
a lot that kind of
retired a little early that basically
said you know i'm not going to go back
to that i got a little for the
government now i'm about to get social
security those people are very very sick
they're going to vote for the gravy
train but if the gravy train is temporal
right unless it's going to be a
permanent shift to socialism we're just
going to keep printing money and keep
handing it to people which can't happen
right our structure in the u.s the u.s
economic structure will not sustain that
then ultimately
you know they want you know low crime
they want lower taxes they want lower
inflation and so they're going to swing
that other way i don't think the 7
million are completely uniquely you know
what someone would say you know
liberally minded just to keep voting for
their check a lot of them are but i was
reading about a sliver of these older
people that were sort of retiring early
and are not giving up what has been you
know a conservative value structure
they're just kind of fed up with the you
know the coveted mandates and everything
that went with the job and they're like
you know what i'm retiring early yeah i
have so much sympathy and respect for
small business owners what they've had
to endure in the last year and now when
they can finally try to get back and
they can't find workers i can't imagine
anything more frustrating than that than
having these open positions and not
being able to fill them and knowing that
you can't run your business like you
normally would they're the ones they're
really the only ones that are affected
right these small business owners it was
dunkin donuts with the sign on there it
says please be patient with the length
of the line if you really want to
complain about it ask for an application
yeah i saw that that's everywhere by the
way you want to pull up an email i just
sent you from a world economic forum did
you guys see the story by world economic
forum that's been shared everywhere
so
here's a story tom of what direction
we're going in okay
you may want to close that while you're
doing that tyler i send it to your
valuetainment email just kind of close
that and do it yourself um so i you know
there's there's an article by a world
economic forum that says the following
by the way somebody reminded me of it
who was it the sergeant wilkie
that
can you help him out to pull this
article up it's we don't have to go that
it's not that technical we just have to
put welcome to 2030. if you just
happened welcome to 2030 i think the
article will come up i own nothing have
no privacy and life has never been
better okay this is welcome to 2030.
there you go
uh go to the first one right there right
that right there okay
uh actually go back go back
uh
uh uh yeah i mean listen we're going in
a direction right now where the article
what the story's about
you don't need to own everything so
yesterday i posted something on f on
facebook about what's going on with gas
prices and one guy
uh i gave the story about what makes
america great okay
you know how do you judge the greatest
country in the world if you think about
how do you judge the greatest country in
the world tom how do you judge the
greatest country in the world david i'm
going to come to you next
uh uh tyler if you haven't seen the
video i'm going to ask you as well i
think you've probably seen the video on
how i present it if not i'm going to ask
you as well
folks if you're listening to this i'm
asking you as well name give me your
formula for how you judge the greatest
country in the world so for example how
do you judge the greatest parent in the
world okay by their offsprings and their
offsprings how you how their grandkids
do you're gonna say that guy was a good
parent right how do you judge a great
coach we were sitting there yesterday
saying who's the greatest coach of all
time you know belichick's got to be at
the top and we had landry we had all
these different guys right based on what
championships bill walsh i think we had
a second all this other stuff how do you
judge the greatest country in the world
i'll throw this out there really quickly
it's um the ability to do whatever you
want with as little government
interference as possible i'll say that
okay david how about yourself how do you
judge the greatest country in the world
give me your formula and i want data i
don't want to be like the grass is green
the flowers smell better you know i want
specific data what makes the country the
greatest country in the world how do you
judge it there's uh transparency in the
government there's honesty there's
security how do you measure that
everybody says we're the most
transparent administration and none of
them are with uh facts that you can back
up accurately and it reads across the
board through all political systems so
for you if if our country is in [ __ ]
yeah i mean we're struggling financially
we're getting attacked by everybody but
i tell you all our problems you define
that as the greatest country in the
world
well i mean hold on
so police are being honest by the way
let's keep going let's keep going tyler
how do you judge the greatest country in
the world well i saw the video on
twitter
so you can't say that right kai if you
haven't seen the video how do you judge
the greatest country in the world i'd
say based on what data and i haven't
seen it i haven't seen it i'd say for me
it'd be in terms of um
having a certain set of people who if
they're willing to put in the work they
can achieve the level of financial
success
and across the board and like how it's
replicatable and people can do it so
time and time over here okay life
liberty and pursuit of happiness is what
you're saying in other words not norway
okay i mean norway's a good life
tom how do you judge the greatest
country in the world i did not see the
video so this is straight the same way
you judge parents i look at the
generations of people and what has
happened to their standard of living i
can measure that i can look at crime
statistics i can look at border security
and invasions and say wow that's the
greatest country in the world they are a
safe people
security for you you have security okay
and i look at each generation has
opportunity to extend itself and i look
at that and over time the american
experiment is number one so i see a lot
of people commenting mitch says freedom
of privacy
greg dinkins says health education
freedom and happiness i don't know who
greg dinkins but thank you for that
jesus rodriguez live in another country
and you will find out great question
point there anyways here's how i judge
the greatest country in the world david
it's very simple for me and and the
analogy i will use for you is in the
following way
say it's friday night it's ten o'clock
okay there is five clubs on the strip
you're 22 years old with your five
buddies and girlfriends you want to go
have a good time you go to the first
club how do you judge which club is
popping how
the line at the front yeah the line
outside baby there you go here's a
question for you how do you judge a
restaurant it's lunchtime the seven of
us want to go eat somewhere right we go
to the restaurant it's 12 15 and you
walk in and what do you see it's packed
you see
what do you say damn this place is
popping right when you go to a
restaurant and the most annoying thing
they say is what can you remove that
please what's the most annoying thing
they say to you you have to wait i'm
sorry there's a one-hour wait in your
mind what do you say a one-hour wait but
then what do you tell yourself damn the
one-hour wait time waiting outside it's
gotta be good i wanna come here i'm
gonna be here an hour early tomorrow
exactly so to all the people who [ __ ]
about america there is not a longer line
to a restaurant aka country than america
where immigrants want to come here i
don't need any other data there's no
line for people wanting to go to germany
there's no line for people wanting to go
to mexico there's no line for people
wanting to go to china there's no line
for people wanting to go to any other
country at the level of u.s and if you
pull up the united nations number for
immigration countries with the highest
level of immigration it's a united
nations number from last year you will
see number one country in the world if a
football game score is 48 to 10 what do
you call that score a shellacking a
blowout okay take a look at the scoring
right there
48.2 million immigrants in u.s russia's
11-6 saudi 10-8 germany 10-2 united uk
8-4
uae 8 france 7-9 canada 7-6 u.s 48
million why if this country is so
horrible why do 48 mil nobody told them
you better come to america this is the
greatest country in the world and people
hate that i spoke at the school last
week and i got up on stage and i said
600 kids second grade to senior year i
said i want to tell you guys something
here before we get into anything else
because it was veterans day they had me
speaking for veterans day said america
is the greatest country in the world
don't ever be too worried about saying
anything else so look you know we can we
can talk about whatever we want to talk
about with this labor shortage oh my
gosh it's unfair it's not fair that
they're doing this it's not fair that
they're doing that yeah go find a
different country and go to it but the
reality of it is 48 million people chose
this over anywhere else fyi if you say
it's based on population
china and india is number one if you say
it's based on land russia is number one
if you say whatever you want to say
based off of people chose here so yeah
maybe we are living in the greatest
country in the world and uh instead of
complaining about it and changing
everything about it that works that
attracts others how about we try to
protect it the way it is because it's
not going to get too easy but i was
reading this book that was sent to me by
amor
it's called the fourth turning by
william strauss and neil howe
uh what the cycles of history tell us
about america's next rendezvous with
destiny and he explains about the fact
that there's four uh
turning uh first one is high an upbeat
era of strengthening institutions that
weakening individualism second turning
is an awakening the passionate era of
spiritual upheaval where the civic order
comes under attack from a new values
regime the third turning is an
unraveling downcast era of strengthening
individualism and weakening institutions
and the fourth turning is a crisis a
decisive era of secular upheaval when
the values regime propels the
replacement of the old civic order with
a new one he explained something in this
book he says we are at a point right now
that we get to choose
how we react today on what's going to
happen the next decade or two if we
[ __ ] about what happened today like
remember back in the days when folks
came back from vietnam and people were
spitting in soldiers faces at the
airports and all these other stories
that you read about and you hear about
hey you shouldn't have gone to war you
know you're this you're that and america
was divided we can choose to be divided
or we can sit there and say listen we
may disagree but we got one thing in
common do we both love america which
america do you love do we love the
america that has to do with freedom why
don't we protect it what do you say
great let's set aside our egos and our
agendas let's agree on one thing
america's great let's keep it that way
that'd be a good starting point that's a
mic drop as far as the lineup to get in
and that's before they started paying
immigrants too a couple hundred grand
enter the country yeah it's you know
there's there's a the idea of gratitude
meant gratitude is such a tough thing
uh to embrace it took me a long time to
embrace gratitude you know this whole
thing that
they say a parenting you go through
three phases you know first you
idolize your father then you demonize
your father then you humanize your
father so the first thing is oh my gosh
my dad is my hero my mom is my hero
and then you get a little older now what
do you say
i hate my dad you guys have no clue what
you're talking about you guys suck stop
kissing me stop touching me stop asking
me what i'm doing with my phone and then
the last phase is
freaking amen my dad was actually not as
bad as i thought he was he was a good
man my mom was freaking amazing you know
all this time i [ __ ] about it this is
this is this is better than what i
thought we're right now at the
demonizing phase of america freaking hey
we are demonizing this great country
nonstop rather than humanizing this
place and telling ourselves how lucky
and grateful we ought to be well the
loudest people are the ones that
humanize things once they're gone right
or once you don't have them exactly so
exactly the humanizing part of america
doesn't have to get there though it
doesn't have to give you but here's the
problem we give too much power to the to
the loud minority we're allowing them to
dictate all this and listen to this
noise it's ridiculous go ahead david i
want to hear your thoughts yeah i think
yeah that's the scary part is that you
start humanizing things once they're
gone and so
i said hopefully he doesn't have to get
to that but will we humanize america
once all our liberties are gone once all
these beautiful things that we love
about this country are gone old days
that would uh
that would really be unfortunate david
what is your uh from the point being
made about how you judge a country how
did you process that yourself on what i
said
i guess just trying to think of
obviously the ideal right just always
living in the truth or the full truth
but then as i was thinking about i mean
that could be like you said so if i tell
you all our terrible finances and that
everything's terrible i mean that means
we're a great country we'll know
and if if you want to have a united
government my other thing was like well
i guess then all parties would be
aligned and everyone working to the same
goal
but that's not good either because there
are countries like that where the whole
government is aligned to one goal and
it's a bad goal and by the way let's
question this whole thing about 100
transparency is 100 transparency uh
necessary do you really want 100
transparency no i don't know i don't
want to know what my parents are arguing
about that's what i'm saying to you my
dad used to tell my mom when they would
argue and they would say listen we can
argue all day long but the kids don't
need to know about it correct these guys
are 6 7 8 10 12 years old in iran
they're already stressed out you want to
add more [ __ ] to their plate stop it we
don't need to do that so i'm glad there
wasn't a hundred percent transparency
from my parents to me and i think this
whole idea about having a hundred
percent transparency if you're 100
transparent with your country today that
means you're also being 100 transparent
with your enemy today why does it make
any sense to be a hundred percent
transparent with your enemy yeah i don't
know i don't know if i uh there used to
be a time that i thought that was like
hey it's the uh what do you call it
yeah i i uh look i yeah we were at the
wedding guys were asking when we're
building the insurance company we're
growing how many challenges we had
and one of the guys fred terrace and
cindy kobos they said uh man you really
kept a lot of things away from us like
scary things said what do you want me to
do do you want me to tell you about it
he says but how did you do that because
we thought everything was perfect i said
that's my job that's what i'm supposed
to do i chose to be the leader i'm not
supposed to tell you all the problems
that's why i chose to so the leaders
need to be taking that responsibility
that way too leadership that is the
burden of leadership yeah my run for
governor and boca raton didn't really go
that well
well thank god bulk is not a state but
you know if you ever chose to run as a
member
that's why i probably didn't go too
early
he's a write-in candidate
there's a lot of old people here i don't
know if they're that gullible though
maybe my campaign manager wasn't that
good you know david's got a lot of the
old american expression you don't always
want to know how the sausage is made
right i mean some things that are kept
secret are better and you know what uh
one more uh to your point pat
the biggest stress relief i think you
can have in life and this is some good
advice i try to teach everybody
that are my children this at least if
you have a life of gratitude your life
is so if you can look at any scenario
and pick out what is the better part of
it as opposed to always going towards
the negative your life is going to be 75
better it's gonna be smoother you're
gonna be happier you're gonna have fewer
problems gratitude i don't disagree i do
not disagree um okay let's go to the
next story disney page five if you want
to go there this is a pretty interesting
story on what disney employees are doing
disney employees begin
relocating from california to florida
business friendly climate this is a fox
business story
some of the 2000 walt disney company
employees who are being moved from
california to florida are already eyeing
up the housing market near orlando
disney announced in july that it would
move 2000 employees from california to
florida and part of the florida business
friendly climate it's not just two
thousand employees it's two thousand
employ uh it's not just two thousand
employees it's two thousand employees
their families and extended families one
realtor said i also kind of panicked and
was like gosh we don't have enough
inventory as it is more buyers coming in
is going to make it very difficult to
win bids for these buyers and we're
trying to help the median price of a
home is far below california sitting at
318 for florida versus
951 in california
did you hear that it's unbelievable 318
times 951 exactly three times higher and
that's wow and that's the state of
california that's not los angeles no
that's not the last thing that's that's
the state
you know i'll jump on this really
quickly because i'm the only one that
doesn't live in florida um you know it's
amazing we go from a story where people
don't want to work he lives i'm sorry
tom it's the same thing right uh go from
a story where people don't want to miss
the palm trees and beach
to where people will
leave everything and cross the entire
country with their family for that job i
think this is going to be fun to do a
follow-up in about a year because these
are great headlines this is very
interesting and you leave california i
totally get it on the business side but
it'll be interesting to see how some of
these families adjust because there will
be culture shock involved in some of
these moves for people if you lived in
california your whole life and you moved
to florida it's going to take an
adjustment it's different right the
weather's different the ocean is on the
opposite side of what you're used to i
find that just weird right you go to the
ocean you always assume you're going
west i bet that took you a little while
too in california now here it's the
exact opposite interesting you know i i
find that you know that's how i figure
out my directions if i'm going towards
the ocean i know north is that way i
gotta admit i haven't thought of that
once yeah that was pretty cool though
but the other thing too i mean there's
just so many aspects of your life if
you're a sports fan how do you get used
to the game starting that much later
you're used to watching a nfl game
starting at six o'clock in prime time or
5 30 and now you're not going to bed
until 1am if you want to stay to the end
of it so it's interesting totally makes
sense these companies are doing it it'll
be interesting to see what type of toll
or what kind of effects this has on
people that have made this move uh it
might be all worth it because of the
cost of you can get such a bigger house
your life can change instantly and and
you know what we know it shonda and i
had to go to arizona on friday you just
feel different when you go into a state
like arizona or you go to texas or you
go to florida like i do every week or
you go to california for a day there's
differences when you can walk into a
place of business and not think did i
bring my mask it's a totally different
world i mean seriously you panic in
california i don't have my mask what do
i do oh my god i don't have it can i
pull my
my shirt up over my face will that work
you know they're getting a little bit
lacked because i think store owners and
business owners are sick of it as well
but it's just different when you come
out here it's freedom it feels wonderful
look i love this story because i
remember when bob iger talked about the
fact that they had to let go of 78 000
employees in california and he was a guy
that was sitting on newsome's board
helping him out right yeah and then he
resigned he says look i'm not playing
this game with you because you're
hurting all these families here while
the businesses around disney world were
doing okay because they were still open
people could still go there and then
fast forward 12 months later 16 months
later florida desantis was seen as an
irresponsible governor now their covet
uh
cases are lower than the state of
california who's like the responsible
state so this is not a good look for
california this is a great look for
florida but i will tell you behind
closed doors a lot of floridians don't
want people from california to come here
and that's straight up
i don't blame you from california to
come to florida there's a bigger story
underneath this right now the the
headline is 2 000 people are going to
drive up the price of housing so they're
selling an expensive house coming to
florida they're going to be able to bid
higher and you know our
and the realtor is saying am i even
going to be able to help you the bigger
story here is that disney is very
quietly
moved 2 000 people from the walt disney
company and these weren't theme park
workers
and they have moved an operation it's
not about the 2000 that are there now
it's about the next thousand that
they're going to be hiring in the next
five years and disney is saying that
florida is a better business climate and
i'm moving a massive division to florida
and they're probably going to get a
little bit of wage moderation and
regulation moderation definitely versus
california the bigger story is the mouse
doesn't want to say out loud that
they're leaving california and they're
very happy to have the narrative be
about this migration of people and stuff
but the mouse is moving a division to
florida because they think it's a better
place to do business and just like texas
when toyota move all those people from
hawthorne california to dallas you know
texas a lot of texas citizens were like
okay so we got a lot of blue people
coming here slowly tinting us on the
vote toward lavender and they're not
looking for that but toyota did it for
economic reasons too nobody wants to go
out and criticize the state of
california in public but there are
businesses that continue to move out big
businesses who try to show this nice
rainbow flag
we're okay with everybody everything's
cool it's all here yay and and donate
politically and stuff while very quietly
and economically moving yeah think of
the decision making involved in moving 2
000 people that's a lot of logistics and
i will say this about disney when that
initial release came out where they said
they're moving these 2 000 workers they
did say that the california business
climate is way less attractive than
florida they did call them out a little
bit so i think to a certain extent
they're not afraid of saying it now if
you're going to make that big of a
decision to move i mean i think you you
know everybody knows why and it's okay
to say it all right let's talk about
just waiting for in and out to move to
florida i've already i've already made
my commitment or not if they come here i
will buy one franchise from them even
though they don't do it anymore i will
gladly buy one from hey you know what i
think pat i think this office will keep
you in business pat that was
that was a novelty story initially but
that thing's got like some real legs i
mean if the actual ceo is talking to the
governor of the state of california
state of florida the state of florida
it's more than just
it's not just like a publicity stunt
david got a shout out yeah
governor mayor david is his
emperor now that's a perfect question
right there okay nbc reveals dirty
little secret people can't afford
inflation just fine this is a news
buster story according to nbc business
correspondent stephanie rule on sunday
today the dirty little secret is that
american public can afford inflation
just fine and they're just uh belating
it uh belly aching it but you just might
have to sell your home or tap your 401k
to survive the winner and the dirty
little secret here while nobody likes to
pay more on average we have the money to
do so she declared for those who own
their homes and value their own homes
are up and while the stock market isn't
the economy you have over half of
american households with some
investments in the market and the market
has hit at record highs but those aren't
the most liquid of assets so is rules
advised for people to sell their homes
and take out a loan so they can afford
to eat what about the people who rent
what about those who rent and we're
relying on eviction moratorium can you
imagine the snobby message from this
stephanie rule saying look you can't
afford it stop bitching that inflation
is affecting you here's what's so crazy
here's what's so crazy a guy said the
other day he says pat you have money why
are you complaining about gas prices i
said do you think gas prices affect me
personally no do you think inflation
affects me personally no matter of fact
do you think inflation has helped me or
hurt me helped you it's helped me
tremendously who do you think inflation
gas prices hurts the most low and middle
lower middle income so the same the 5
000 jobs you made so the same with your
company so the same people the same
people who claim they care for the
little guy
the low-income middle-income families
are going up there saying stop
complaining you can afford inflation go
spend the money on gas and go shopping
do you realize the level of hypocrisy
when it comes down to the conversations
of inflation go ahead tom
so let's say this was
business roundtable
guest patrick bet david
conservative capitalist from florida
what was it you that just said the exact
same thing she said what would be the
reaction from bernie sanders all the way
down oh my goodness listen to this guy
he doesn't give a damn about the worker
it's a double standard this is
horrifying when i read this i was like
where is the outrage where is the
outrage if jeff bezos who's not
necessarily conservative came out and
said this oh there here it is this guy
you know serfs and lords here he is out
there just squeezing a little people yet
a a talking a liberal talking head is
allowed to say this never mind that it's
logically bankrupt that you'll continue
to sell all of your assets until you're
down to zero till you get through a
nuclear winter that you don't know how
long it's going to be i i the double sin
this this thing was just horrifying to
me it's a double standard it's
wrong-headed logic and if anybody else
said that they'd be crucified
anybody surprised though well no are you
surprised i'm not surprised i'm not
surprised but
you know i'm not surprised but i was i
was shocked in that i was not i was not
surprised but i was the same shocked got
it make sense go ahead tom well i don't
know if it's this chair this microphone
but i'm not as offended with her
statement as you guys are
i don't know if it's adam channeling me
through this microphone or whatnot you
know i will say this
i am maybe not quite as offended by the
statement for one reason she's a tv
personality maybe she look what she did
i know her name now i didn't know it
before now i i don't know if she was
doing it for that reason but i also will
say this i think everybody speaks from a
level of perspective
and and pat i think her perspective is i
make a pretty damn good salary as an nbc
correspondent
it's not affecting me yet so i'm
speaking from that perspective i don't
know if this was an overarching
commentary of how it affects all of
america but just to take a little bit
different side here
i can see where she's coming from a
little bit because but it hasn't hit her
big yet because right now prices across
the board are six percent higher than
they were a year ago and that number is
going to go higher and it's going to
cross many many more categories listen
than it already is it's it's interesting
you're saying that i remember running a
sales office and one day i look up i'm
25 26 years old 95 of all my sales guys
were under the age of 25 okay
uh they were all hooking up with each
other
i would come on sundays no joke on my
office and on sundays they're on the
floor having sex at my sales office
that's how crazy the sales office was
wow no i'm not i'm not even i would tell
them i'm like listen go go to do from
place and they'll say look we don't have
a different place i said dude i'm
finished up i'll come back in i'd give
him 10 minutes i'll come back i'm
telling you the true story and then
here's what i realized these 20 year
olds these 21 year olds were broke
they didn't have a market everybody else
they knew we're going to clubs they were
rolling they were doing ecstasy they
were talking about what's the best g to
use and all this other crap and one day
i'm like i'm done don't give me a phone
number for another person that's 21
years old i only want to call clients or
people who are interested in doing
business that are above 25 years old
married with kids so watch what i did as
a single person sometimes when we talk
about kids what do single people
typically do i don't care why i got kids
i don't think about what it is to have
kids right right but i realized the
reason why everybody in my office was
single was because i only knew the life
of a person who was what single so i
said wait a minute if you
want to truly be able to get a clientele
that's making money that's married with
kids you have to understand what it is
to be married with kids and the pains
that parents go through right so this
girl that's talking about this inflation
deal that everybody else can go suck it
up and do whatever they're doing she's
not putting herself in the situation of
a single mother right now with two kids
trying to do her best to work in home
school in the state of california and
trying to make the whole thing happen
and this kid is having to go through
this the last 18 months all she's
thinking about is the people she's
around all the time so no i don't
understand her rhetoric that she's got
she's living in a different world
completely out of that but that is the
whole thing like that that is the whole
thing about rich people that lost
perspective of what it was wants to be
low income in middle america if you
can't connect with them you lose train
social experiment go live on their wage
for a month and then complain it's an
insult if i'm somebody that's making 28
bucks an hour and i'm trying to do my
best to support my husband my wife my
kids i'm offended by her comments that's
all it is i'm not offended by it it
doesn't do nothing to me
zero i am not at all directly impacted
by this but i know tens of millions of
families who are and i think uh tom had
a great point in terms of if this was an
a person on the republican side or a
rich person
god forbid that said something like this
then they'd be like oh you're just
saying it because you're this or that
they'd be totally railing against it as
opposed to just being oh well i guess it
is what it is yeah it's just listen when
you lose perspective you no longer
connect with people bush senior went
through it where the lady asked him
asked him a question about the fact that
hey how does that affect you
and then he gave an answer saying you
don't think it affects me and then
clinton came in and says let me tell you
what we do in the state of arkansas and
he won
and he was right because bush lost
perspective on how to connect with
families that are struggling with this
the moment you can't do that
you're done with it but the ironic thing
about this is the audience for her is a
left-leaning i know voting and those are
the people that are suffering the most
right and they're the ones that are
least effect offended probably by this
because they're used to having this
rhetoric thrown at them the classic
limousine liberal
right uh uh okay so let's go to the next
story here that we got
uh
you want to do the economist larry
summers first let's do that obama's
economist larry summers slams biden on
inflation saying it doesn't look so
transitory page six if you want to go
there uh
let me see over here okay so here we go
uh uh larry summers who was the
secretary treasurer under clinton and
directed the national economic council
under obama said on cnn that inflation
is going to be unavoidable for the near
future i think the odds
are that we're going to have inflation
of a kind we haven't seen in 30 years
which already happened until either the
fed takes some significant move with
respect to monetary policy which i think
what he's saying is increasing rates or
until there's some kind of accident that
disrupts the economic growth we are
enjoying what is he talking about
summer's continued by pointing out that
he thinks the biden administration is
acting incorrectly and making the
situation worse i think the fed has made
a significant mistake in the approach
that is uh it's taken by doubling down
on massive fiscal stimulus we had at the
beginning of the year and really easy
monetary policy let me read this one
more time from the obama camp i'm going
to read this one more time folks if
you're listening to this the obama camp
you ready i think the fed has made a
significant mistake on the approach it's
taking by doubling down on massive
fiscal stimulus huh so he's saying
stimulus is not a good thing a massive
fiscal stimulus we had at the beginning
of the year
and uh with really easy monetary policy
aren't they trying to push the next two
three four trillion dollar the 1.75 yeah
they're trying to push the next one they
want more than 1.75 but okay so what are
your thoughts about what he's saying
here with inflation tom i'm going to go
to you first it just i mean
when you look at where the source is and
that's the most
it's the most unbelievable thing and
then i'm looking down the road because i
don't know how you can argue against
inflation right now it is coming it is
coming in a much much bigger way we've
only seen the beginning of it
what is this going to do to them next
year or in the 2022 elections right the
midterms so this the just seeing this
bickering when they're but this is just
common sense you cannot argue against it
and i think for his credibility he can't
say anything but this because it makes
sense i think though that's why they're
not pushing for it though the 2022
middle midterm election that if they
increase the rates before then things
are going to slow down it's going to be
worse they're
my guess would be they're banking on
rather let it roll through the midterm
elections and then kind of do damage
control on the back end as opposed to
try to limit it on the front end so so
here's here's uh so can we all agree
that the face of the democratic party is
still obama um would you agree who would
you say the face of the democratic party
as far as he's still popular yes but
would you say here's the face like what
he says everybody follows somebody let
me just throw some names out there and
you tell me no no he's the ef hutton
that's what i'm saying party okay cool
so if he is the ef hutton and he's the
voice
do you think behind closed doors a
serious question folks i'm curious to
know what you say about this serious
question because i i had a big debate
with a conservative the other day he
wasn't too happy about my position on
obama okay where i feel obama is today
um here's a question with obama how
often do you think obama and biden speak
today
pretty regularly i'm going to say
infrequently i'm going to say not that
free you're saying pretty regularly
that'd be my guess tell me what pretty
regularly means uh i'd say on a weekly
basis once a week yeah tom you agree
with that
sorry guy hell no yeah i don't think
he's looking for advice from bob i think
it's every day
really hell no so you're saying how
often so how often you think him and
obama speak christmas and birthdays
really you're going there i don't know
how do i what do you think do i think
obama's speaking to a lot of the people
i agree with that yes okay so what do
you think i think politically obama's
trying to distance himself from joe
biden so i think very very infrequently
very very infrequently okay so okay if
that's the case do you think obama's
sitting here himself saying look
i don't want my legacy to be tied to joe
because i think joe's about to go to the
gutter and i don't want them to say my
policies did this because if biden goes
to the gutter and everybody says and joe
says i'm just following all the policies
that obama had and obama's going to be
like wait a minute you got to stop
saying that because i i don't want my
policies to be your policies because
your policies are really hurting
everything that's going on right now in
america i don't want to associate myself
with you with this by the way uh our
buddy here to my right's got a lowrider
and he's got these
global warming
no i think there's something there's
something here that's very interesting
of the globe
looks like two globes but anyway the um
you've got
in the obama administration
summers and geithner did a really good
job of taking the handoff from bush
it the economy didn't go off the cliff
they had 0-809 they had things to deal
with they had tarp
and i thought they did a really good job
of preventing just carnage on the
financial side in the recovery stage and
09 and 10 were great on the recovery
stage after the crash of oa and i think
these guys are sensible
really sensible and i think they're also
thinking about their
legacy and i think in the democratic
party there's a bunch of things moving i
think they don't want joe to run again
next time i think they want to absolute
castrate any opportunity that there is
for that and i think that obama doesn't
want his legacy to be tarnished and i
honestly think that summers and geithner
really want and summer speaking here but
remember tim was always right next to
him
i think they really
want things to be better and i think
he's pointing out look guys you can't go
further you can't and if there is you
say that you're just waiting
because you want to you know wait to do
something for the economy so that you
don't get accused of making a mistake
going into the midterm i think you guys
are making a mistake with that action
and i think it's as simple as simple as
that and i think larry's unafraid to
speak i don't think it's a hit piece i
don't think he's been unleashed to go
after him i think he's out there saying
hey i did this job i i was here in the
middle of a crisis guys i did not have
eight years of peace and prosperity do
you think obama is moving further and
further and further to the right
you think ever since obama from day one
of obama taking presidency to today do
you think gradually he's moving a little
bit more to the center
i'm asking a question it's either yes or
no i'm saying not necessarily i don't i
don't i think so i think so you don't
think necessarily no i really like it
well okay but what is the upside for him
even commenting right now did somebody
reach out this is strategic he did this
for a reason and this is less than one
year into biden's term i really try to
go there okay
i think obama is disassociating himself
with biden to the point where he's going
to dictate who runs next so
this is not a coincidence this this gets
out there for a reason obama's still
young he's still very very relevant
right he might be the wizard of oz
pulling all the strings in the
background who knows and i'm trying to
think who who would be his hand-picked
is it michelle i don't know well that's
what i'm talking about i think they're
trying to castrate it they said it was
transitory it doesn't look so transitory
they're wrong that's what he's saying
you're wrong they said it was a few
specific factors doesn't look to be a
few specific factors he's saying again
they're wrong so how many times can he
say in a very polite political statement
they're wrong they're wrong they're
wrong
it sounds like a republican saying that
that's exactly right you know it's so
bizarre it would be more inflammatory if
it was coming from the period and this
is his guy this guy he campaigned for
so so so again going back to the
question do you think he's moving to the
center i think so i think he's moving
more to the center more towards the
center i think obama 08 put on a persona
that was more liberal than he really was
do you think obama i think it's going to
come back do you think obama 08 is aoc
2021 or do you think obama 08
is bill clinton 1996.
i'm hoping that's going well clinton ran
to the center i think obama 08 he was a
little more he was a little more like
obamacare all that stuff affordable
health care okay what i'm going to
promise to you and all this but i think
that he's been unmatched as a far more
of a moderate
say listen we ain't going to 40 percent
uh yeah that's a good point you know a
pat a good way to judge it is michelle
you got my own phone got my whole phone
give me the michelle give me a sale and
give me an old phone
i gotta call the irs
do i solve the irs on speed dawg let's
see who he basically let's see who he
campaigns for in 2022 if he's out there
for aoc and omar and some of these
others because i don't think he'll do
that i i agree i don't think he'll be
able to i don't think he can that would
ruin for him that would ruin i don't
think they'll listen bernie aoc
is a very very smart guy whether you
like him agree with him it doesn't
matter you have to respect an opponent
that guy is a very very smart guy and he
knows what he's doing he he's a he's a
your next 15 moves type of guy
knowing what he's got going on anyways
here's the next one here nearly half the
democrats
want a candidate other than biden to run
in 2024 a poll
reveals this is page seven interesting
let's take a look at this see where this
goes
uh by the way how many of you guys are
democrats who are watching this who are
comfortable commenting that yes
as a dem who voted for biden i would
like somebody else to run in 2024 then
biden if yes comet if you are don't put
it if you're not
just if yes comment i'm curious or you'd
like him to stay and tell us why so here
we go nearly half of democrats want a
candidate other than biden to run in
2024 this is a new york times story this
is not new york post this is new york
times over 40 of democrats believe their
party will have a better chance of
winning in 2024 president biden is
replaced at the top of the ticket
according to a poll released on monday
44 of democrats and democrat leaning
independent want other candidates on the
ballot 36 percent want to keep buying
and 20 aren't sure
uh a marist national poll found among
republicans and gop leading independence
50 percent believe former president
donald trump gives them the best chance
of retaking the white house 35 would opt
for someone else and 14 donor and just
44 of americans approve of joe biden's
uh doing while 49
disapprove thoughts okay here's the
scary part this is a loaded question
what is the alternative right there
could be a worse alternative than joe
biden you mean kamala yes i do and maybe
somebody else but primarily her so
they're definitely joe biden would look
really good to me if it was kamala
harris as the alternative so this is
interesting i think people are disgraced
by some of his actions he he's not
acting like a president they don't even
know how much he's capable of doing on a
day-to-day basis so i can understand the
democrats wanting somebody else in that
poll but or running in 2024 but who
could it possibly be and if it's kamala
that's a scarier thought i got i got a
list here on this website uh they they
have newsom as a potential the top okay
they have michael bennett uh as a
potential senator from colorado they
have aoc they have kamala harris they
have nina turner they have howard
schultz again they have mark cuban who
could
corey booker pete budachedge and then
you got some of the other cuomo's and
all these other guys you know gretchen
wittmeyer you know uh
same same name so who could potentially
win 2024 outside of
biden i think well first of all i think
they're going to break ranks cory booker
wanted it so badly he wanted to be vp so
badly and he was just
disgusted that he lost i mean he was
really not a team player when the vp
selection came he wanted to be that guy
so i think they're gonna break ranks and
a guy like cory booker is gonna run so
there's a few of these that are gonna go
that still have good support and are
coming from a position that they're not
too this word politically volatile and
cory booker's not so incredibly
politically volatile he's going to get
his support i think he's going to go and
i
i i discount the howard schultz as i
discount the mark cuban's sort of vanity
picks
populist picks but i think they're going
to break ranks and i don't think that
this is going to be
the central party the democrat party is
going to be able to select what they
want to do now i don't think that kamala
harris is going to be able to get
support i think shit's a non-starter she
i mean kamala has more disapproval than
than biden does so i don't think that
i'm not i'm not worried about that
aspect but the other thing is when
you're saying there's not a lot of
people i mean think about two years ago
was descendants the name two years ago
they're still two and a half two years
to go until they're running so there's a
lot of time very good for somebody to
step up to make some speech to rise like
a shooting star i mean look at uh cuomo
how fast he was a shooting star and then
went to obama nobody knew who he was so
i'm that aspect i mean there's a lot of
a lot of time where they can find
somebody who can create a situation like
that on that end they don't have a deep
bench today no it's going to be a draft
pick guys what you're saying exactly
you're saying so so let me ask you how
often does a draft pick like obama come
and win a championship for you or super
bowl you think there's a mahomes out
there you think there's an obama out
there it's tough to kind of lean on
somebody like that to come out to bet on
that is a risky strategy so let me ask
you when is the next dnc what is the
next convention they're going to be
having is it the 103
when is the next convention that uh uh
that that'll be the year the actual
election so that's pretty scary because
they need something next year like the
democrats need to create their own big
convention next year call it whatever
you want to call it have a lineup of
speakers come for two or three days and
see if one pops with an audience and say
that may be our guide yeah well they
have two problems they've got the
midterm problem we know what's going on
there is that it how bad do you think
it's going to be we haven't asked you
yet i think it's going to be very bad i
think the midterm is going to be a big
swing i think it's going to be like the
you know remember the obama swing the
first term 63. that's right not one
republican incumbent lost
and what was it 12 republican rookies
were elected it was horrifying
so i i think the midterms could be that
bad or even worse that's the first
problem and then the second problem is
how do we unify our party and what do we
unify around because we're not trump
and we can fix the economy both are
unavailable
okay
one because what i'm not trump
good i think people just uh keep
discounting michelle obama i mean 2024
desantis isn't going to run he's already
announced trump is going to run in 2024
desantis said he ain't running right
he's running for he's running for
re-election of governor in florida in
2022. so he's not going to run in 2024
no but he has to say that if he's
running for governor next year because
he can always leave yeah he i mean he
can always buy
like why would why would you vote for
him then if two years later he's gonna
bounce or and eighteen months and he's
gotta get one of his people in there
when he does yeah
interesting bishman just gave five bucks
and he said i voted for biden in 2020
but i want a younger candidate in 2024
desantis is interesting if the dems
can't find a good candidate good for you
okay very reasonable good for you
uh okay next story we got howard stern
about i'm going to read that what trump
said what trump's poll are looking like
today which is very interesting to see
trump's poll this way
donald trump beats
joe biden in latest 2024 election poll
and no this is not fox or new york post
this is newsweek okay the poll released
friday by emerson college shows trump
narrowly beating biden in a hypothetical
match up while neither trump nor biden
is backed by the majority of the voters
the former president is currently two
points ahead of the current president
trump is supported by 45 percent of
registered voters while biden is back by
only 43 percent meanwhile 11 percent of
registered voters said they want to vote
for someone else and just one percent
said they remain undecided emerson's
polling also shows that biden's approval
rating continues to dip while his
disapproval rating surges upward in
september was 46 percent of registered
voters approved or biden 47 disapproved
now outside of november he's at 41
wow
uh said they approve of the president
while 50 chimed in their disapproval and
it's not looking
too good so trump
trump being the guy that loves polls he
probably loves that oh yeah can i say
something you'll go forward this feels
like uh you break up with your
girlfriend and you find a new one and
then
you find the new one isn't any better
and you're like i kind of miss the last
one and then you just end up with the
last one and then it's just
back and forth do you want to talk about
it
pat i miss or something
that's exactly what it sounds like it's
just like the grass isn't greener like i
tried it didn't work
by the way the 11 that want to vote for
someone else when they walk into that
voting booth they're going to vote for
jackson or benjamin you know they're on
the 20 they're on the 100 they're going
to vote with their wallet when they walk
into that voting booth and they're
probably going to break more for trump
but they don't want to say it out loud
but they're going to vote with their
wallet i think there's one thing here
though with the you have disapproval
numbers but you also have like hate
numbers people are viciously opposed to
certain people and especially when it
comes to
either biden or um trump that there's
people who are very against like with
let's say it's a biden trump run again
it's it's more of the question of who do
you not want more and that's who they're
going to vote against so i think a big
thing as well is there's who would you
vote for but then there's also who would
you vote against because a big thing as
well
the people who wouldn't vote like if i
don't care then you don't vote but that
you need to get those people to either
hate the person or to like him enough to
vote and that's more what's interesting
robert robert sheridan just gave 10
bucks and he said dems got caught with
their pants down in 2016. they will
never let someone like trump win again
do you think he's right i don't yes but
i don't think trump's running i i'm
going to stand by that i don't think
it'll be biden versus trump
i really don't why not 100 bucks you
know well
never talk about my great predictions
and i make a lot of them
a lot of them a very high percentage
we're we're looking forward to hearing
one go ahead
many of them i'll give you a whole lot
next time i'm here i'm going to bring a
list next you should because it's so
easy to take shots at me
because i'm bold and don't and fearless
hang on i got my wallet first i want the
odds and then i want to know how i can
bet okay well trump's not running give
us the odds okay let me ask you a
question
do you read anything into the fact that
the trump family is selling their hotel
in washington dc i do a little bit he
might not be running in 2024 you know
they're selling their hotel tom
predicted i'd be governor of boca
i'm projecting right now
um so so you're saying they're doing
that because they don't think they're
going to be living in dc anytime soon or
what what an advantage that was you know
hosting people when you are the
president and maybe you don't think you
need it down the road i just think that
the more powerful forces will convince
him not to run
then run i don't i don't think he's
going to be running i hope i hope we can
look back at this in three years and say
i was right well here's here's some
people if you want entertainment you
want him to run if you like
entertainment you want him to run
because here's what howard stern just
said howard stern just made a bold
prediction about donald trump's 2024 run
this is a the list story during a recent
episode of his hit series on series xm
shows stern floated the idea running for
2024 against donald trump the
well-respected interviewer quipped that
he is primarily primed to totally beat
his ass in fact stern considers running
against trump his civic duty he said
since it means potentially stopping a
controversial politic politician from
securing a second term i would just sit
there and play that effing clip of him
trying to fix the election over and over
again stern said referring to the now
infamous call trump made to brad
attempting to talk to the georgia
secretary of state into engineering
proof of election fraud and his on his
behalf there's no way i'd lose turn
co-host robin quivers said
agreements that if trump decides to run
again you have to run against him you
can't leave it to the democrats
interesting you think stern would run
you think this is just one of those
gibberish stuff that he's talking about
he's talking head and he does what
talking heads do and you know i will say
this howard stern has become completely
irrelevant by choice there's a serious
problem with him i think i guarantee you
sirius has serious regrets about
re-upping his contract last year he
doesn't want to be there you know he
took the summer off he took june july
august off he took it off he got it into
his contract he is so bitter he he's so
fearful his his shtick is so old right
now and i'm a huge howard stern fan and
i guarantee you if you ask any howard
stern fan out there right now they're
not into it anymore because he's just so
bitter he's so angry he never leaves his
house in the hamptons he's so
disconnected from everything that's
going on this worked in the 90s when he
was going to run for governor and he
said something like this he'd get a real
rally but right now he's just saying it
because he's out of material so i'm
having dinner with marvin and dee del
valle in l.a at palau's winning
and conversation comes about trump he's
asking do you think trump's going to run
and i gave him my feedback on what i
think is going to happen
and he says you know what's my biggest
concern about trump i said what's that
he says trump used to sell the dream
okay he used to excite he used to sell
the dream he used to say america is this
america is that america is this and he
says for whatever reason over the years
he got so bitter and it was only about
going against the people and you know
just being animosity berating all these
enemies and all this stuff i said you
know what it reminded me of he said what
i said if anybody in trump's camp hears
this you may want to consider this
although there's not a lot to be
considered but
if you do consider this here's what i
would say
say you have a team of a hundred sales
guys that work for you okay if you got
100 sales guys that was a lot of people
having sex on the floor yeah if they're
under 25 for sure so that office would
need to be sponsored by trojan but let's
just say you do have an office of 100
sales people okay here's what the
demographic's going to look like out of
your 100 sales guys one of them is going
to be the dominator that's beating and
crushing everybody that example that
everybody gets annoyed because he or she
makes more money than everybody else by
mile
they're gonna have four or five top
performers okay
that are stars but not the superstar
then you're gonna have 10 people that
are doing good okay then you got the
middle people that are like showing up
they're not consistent they're
inconsistent but the same way you have
the one guy that's a super true believer
in you you have the one guy that cannot
stand you despises you every word you
say he just hangs on that to use it
during lunch to tell the guys did you
hear what tom said did you hear what tom
said this is why tom's not a good leader
we should go work somewhere else right
and then you have about 10 complainers
that follow that one big deceptive guy
right okay
when a sales leader gets up and speaks
200 guys if you talk to your group as if
you're only trying to prove that
deceptive guy the negative guy wrong
you're going to lose your audience you
have to get up and talk to the 80
percent that are willing to have
somebody sell them the dream trump
stopped talking to people that were
open-minded and he only talked to his
enemies you got to get you got to forget
about the enemies that are going to be
there they're going to say what they're
going to say if you would have sold the
dream it would have been a little bit
more about hey america's great america
is this america's that that messaging
went away a little bit so yeah look if
if trump decides to go run again the
messaging would need to change a little
bit approach would need to change a
little bit because if he goes the same
way
the results are going to be the same i
totally agree with that and here's the
other thing is part of his motivation
for running payback and getting revenge
and i have one more term i can do
whatever the hell what do you think i'd
say it definitely is an element involved
in that it's the same thing with cuomo
thinking about running for attorney
general it's probably the main reason
why he would want to you think it is a
revenge thing for trump what percentage
do you think is revenge for trump
between
13 to 24 percent here we go
i think about these things i don't throw
out random numbers
sounds very random but that is not
random
there's a low and a high it's like
instead of saying 80 percent
76 but by the way i i don't think it's
13 i think it's a pretty high number
that is actually i think it's higher too
i don't think it's 13
i think it's you guys embarrass me watch
what i'm gonna do to you i think there's
an element of that taking place
yeah i think there's an element of that
taking place and i think there's the
other element you know what the other
element is you know what's the cool
thing about
somebody leaving you and talking trash
about you and then a year two years
later saying man freaking hey i miss
that guy i s
i don't want to say this but you know
you know what i'm saying
that's right mary mary if you're
listening david loves you david loves
you he cries every day in front of my
office saying what do i need to do get
her back if you're listening please
i can explain the text messages
text messages get back to you that dm he
sent it out one girl it was a mistake go
ahead tyler i just i think one of the
best things that happened to trump was
getting kicked off of social media
because everybody hated trump they said
no no more mean tweets well now you
don't have them now trump's not out
there running his mouth all the time 24
hours a day unfiltered trump you lose
that so people like david said it's like
an ex-girlfriend they start to rethink
and say well it wasn't that bad yeah he
needs a different approach
you were at mar-a-lago recently right
yeah what's the vibe out there i mean
he's living there isn't he
fired up is what it was
fired up and
uh lit up is what it was so
kellyanne was there jared was there it
was a american first policy institute
you know the whole uh uh
idea of uh low taxes low regulation
larry kudlow was there was was more like
a business uh
principles then it was more about the
political stuff and i think trump gave a
90-minute speech you know what he looked
like he looked like he was campaigning
that's what it looked like all right
look i was campaigning so we're gonna
see what's gonna end up happening but uh
uh
confidence was pretty up there with a
lot of interesting influences question i
have a question if if say biden and
trump ran do you think on any party they
try to split the bone like they're any
break out and try to run
what do you mean like a ross perot style
in terms of more somebody that's not oh
i see what they're like
would the republican party split would
the democratic party split would both of
them split i say there's more of a
chance of it happening in 2024 than in
the past i think it's a possibility i do
listen which party then here's listen
here's what i'd like to see here's what
i'd like to see i think
as a strategist if you're a strategist i
consider myself a strategist where i'm
seeing what i would do if i'm giving any
kind of counsel to somebody right this
is a very good time for somebody to be a
hero this is a very very good time for
somebody to come in and be a hero okay
and from coming from a place i'm saying
listen here's where i'm coming from this
is your campaign you know everybody's
campaigning around obamacare everybody
is entitled to having health insurance
right forward or dream or change or
whatever right trump's was make america
great again you know you know what the
campaign should be
make america unified again something
about unify right so think about if
somebody ran on unification today and
they went up there and they said look
here's what i want to do let me tell you
what we differ in we different this this
this this fine let me tell you what we
agree on family
so are we gonna let seven things that we
disagree on
outweigh the 98 things that we agree on
okay here's my goal you're not going to
like all the decisions i make because my
goal is to bring this more to the center
and unify right now we are either tilted
to the left or we're tilted to the right
here's the problem if you're tilted to
the left you keep doing circles if
you're tilted to the right you keep
those circles the only way they're going
to keep moving forward is to get a
little bit more to the center so i would
like to see somebody from like a
like i don't even want to say rock but i
would like to see somebody that's coming
in
that is not afraid of losing a few coup
points from their side of the aisle to
say listen man unifying america is more
important than getting those cool points
that's how you convert too and it's
especially there's the silent middle you
need to win time right now to do it oh
my god people crave that time right now
to do it the thing is it has to be
authentic i don't think you can just
automatically uh turn yourself into
saying that this is going to be who i
agree so if someone comes from that
business background or something that's
inspiring and motive people want to hear
that right now they're craving it who
would that be who would that be to come
that can give that message well obama is
one for sure i think obama could unify
well if he wanted to i think he has that
power because he does have that type of
charisma and who's he who's he gonna
knight
to carry that
i'm just thinking about people right now
that have the actual
gravitas to do it have the collateral
politically to do it and have the
personality
um no that's what i'm asking so i agree
with what you said about obama but who's
he gonna knight who's the person with
the gravitational thing that you're
talking about that obama can come and
say
it's got to be somebody very very close
to him that he trusts and it can't be
some random sound crazy that they throw
but you know who i think you know a lot
michelle no no
you know who i think would be great um
to to be able to do that and he has no
interest in doing that
it's and listen hang tight before people
flip out
i think it's a person like rogan
i think that's the kind of a person that
could pull it off
i think it's a person with a personality
like him who
brought a bernie sanders in and he says
i think he makes sense
cool and then he brought tulsi gabbard i
think she makes sense
and he is now in the center where he
pushes back and saying here's what i'm
trying to see if i'm going to fix myself
or not without relying hey i got good
after two days later
i think he could pull it off but i don't
think he has any interest in doing that
at all but it's a personality
like him it can't be too ambitious of a
person because if it's too and i'm not
saying joe's not ambitious it's not the
point that he's not ambitious joe's
living the life that he wants to live
today like it's like when i was on the
podcast with him i'm like he's like i
have no interest on the company you want
me to do more stuff add more stuff to my
plate no i'm good so he's a systematic
guy that he's living a life right now
that i bet is like his dream life yeah
he doesn't he has his buckets and he
fills him up but i think i think he does
very well with enemies i think he does
very well with uh
dealing with enemies i think he knows
how to uh bring the other person's guard
down i think he sat down with some of
the smartest guys in in the world i
don't know i think a personality like
that could pull it off uh when you think
about it candace owns candace would be a
trump type of a personality shapiro it
has to be somebody who's not too
too uh confrontational but also they're
not willing to back away from it it's
more kind of question what i'm saying
you're coming in as yeah let's solve
this as opposed to i'm going to prove
why you're let's talk about it let's
talk about it what am i what am i not i
agree what are you not seeing i think
it's a guy i like
well there's somebody that has a thick
skin who's built something who doesn't
really care because they're going to be
attacked they have to give away five to
six years of their life they have to
give it away i don't know
listen
it would be a very funny campaign uh the
joe rogan experience you know president
rogan if he ran for office that would be
daily podcast from the white house
podcast number
3147 it could get more of a reach
that's what's crazy
you know him doing press conference with
smoking weed and it's just like hey how
are you doing the only thing though
um spotify would have to up his contract
by like a billion dollars oh my god
he would be like howard stern saying i
need four years off four years off i'll
come back to but i need about four years
up we'll see what happened next four
years but i think we need a personality
like that anyways uh next story next
story to go into do you guys want to
talk about the beto story the da let's
do the da story it's a funny story go to
page eight and then we'll go to kamala
and biden so page eight i just think
this is just pathetic when you think
about this d.a stop saying mexican
cartel to peace mexico recently retired
agency official says the daily caller
the director for drug enforcement
administration also known as dea
officials to now use the term mexican
cartel came directly from the biden
administration to ease relations with
the mexican government two recently
retired d.a officials said one recently
retired d.a official said that when the
new administration came in the
department of justice doj
required dea to submit news interviews
requests for approval he said that the
doj declined many of the national news
requests
on top of the language guidance but
eventually eased up and allowed some of
the to do local interviews where he used
the term mexican drug cartel and called
each by its name they want us to call uh
uh to say mexican cartels the [ __ ]
officials they didn't want us to send
cartels i think they wanted us to just
say uh transnational criminal
organization transnational criminal
organization because i don't think they
want to lay all the blame on mexico they
thought it was misleading but they
didn't want didn't get us a lot
they weren't very transparent with
certain things so there you go mexican
cartels we can't say that anymore
i actually don't have a problem with
that i really if you're trying to
cooperate with the country of mexico and
try to take care of these drug cartels
which do exist i it's all branding i
wouldn't i if i was mexico i wouldn't
want that thrown in there
it's real i mean thousands of people are
being murdered every year how they can't
stop it i don't know so let me ask you a
question so did it bother you when trump
kept saying the china virus did not at
all it didn't bother me it did not
bother me at all so this is so why would
this
and i'll tell you why it's very simple
china's an enemy of our country mexico
is not i have no problem getting the
blame on china let me ask you a question
nobody sent mexico as an enemy but
everybody's mixing tells our enemy did
you see the shooting that happened two
people just died in cancun it's terrible
this week did you horrible how they're
targeting these uh these what do you
call a resorts that they're going to god
knows how many times we've been over
there and they just went in with a mask
and shot a bunch of people up yeah it's
terrible but all i'm saying is if this
would help them shut down these drug
cartels i guess i don't have a
tremendous problem like branding more
egg shells to walk up who's even going
to remember transnational criminal
organization
it's too big of a war for someone like
me
esl i think mexican cartel is easy i
wouldn't even be able to spell it well
ricky would be really upset because
that's tco anyways first of all
here's here's here's the reality do you
think mexican cartels are offended that
you're not calling a mexican cartels oh
they're so well they're probably sitting
there saying how dare you call us
transnationally
pat they have a different way of
canceling people so with machine gun
i don't know what to tell you so biden
and kamala's relationship is in crisis
as their poll rating crash just one year
her staff feuds over why she is being
sidelined with no
win migration task while president's
team
say they've given up on her already huh
let's see what the story looks like here
uh on page eight this is a daily mail
story biden is rumored to be considering
moving harris to supreme court as
backdoor method of selecting a new vp
supreme court here we go the president's
staff are frustrated by her appalling
polling figures
even worse than biden harris and her top
aides are furious with biden for handing
her no win issues like the border crisis
they also claim that the president is
not defending girl while looking for
after white men pete buddhich biden's
staff are privately disappointed with
harris over self-inflicted controversies
like her awkward laughter when asked
about visiting the border by nbc lester
holt publicly the white house insists
the relationship between biden and
harris remains uh harmonious what a word
and productive do you think they have a
good relationship today no
did you see yesterday when he was
signing uh the what do you call it the
1.3 trillion dollar bill
how kamala was standing outside and one
of the guys like no come stand over here
and the way she was standing over him
you just have to say language it's very
awkward very awkward when he was signing
you just got to see it
and you make a decision for yourself but
i i i is biden try to distance himself
from kamala like obama's trying to
distance himself from obama uh from
biden right now you think that's kind of
i think there's some parallels i do
because well a
biden didn't pick her okay and ameri
arranged marriages generally don't work
right especially when you start off by
calling someone a racist and then you
marry him so this thing had no chance of
working the she's so ambitious are you
kidding me she would not be satisfied
being in the supreme court there's no
pub in that there's no glamour no way
this is going to be a big thorn for him
coming up in the next three years it's
going to be a major issue for joe biden
what's going to happen with her because
she's not going to be content just being
in the background she's not going to put
up with it no way and they're feeding
they're feeding the media both of their
sides are feeding the media stories over
the weekend cnn was borderline
hysterical the front page
where you had a puff piece on you know
examining kamala harris's life in
politics and then you had two different
stories on discord in harris um
in harris's office of the vice president
is a growing concern for the white house
well who planted that there was two
unnamed sources of the white house who
have spoken the condition of anonymity
you look at that so they're both
planning stories and are both posturing
in position i think biden is distancing
himself from her because they know about
her ratings and it doesn't help him
there's no assistance he can get from
her california ratings glow there's
nothing there's nothing that she can do
there's no website yeah just down it's
shocking he picked her to be honest with
you
that's the point you you just said it he
did not pick her but it is shocking that
she was the vp she is the vp is it even
possible look at all the women all the
women were going to give him something
that he didn't need he didn't need
hawaii he didn't need he's going to get
it anyway he didn't need minnesota he's
going to get it anyway he didn't in
california he's going to get it anyway
and there is all of this other
interesting you know decisions that were
going in there if you take a look at you
you look at things that were really
close he needed virginia now he got
virginia but you see what i mean if you
looked at that electoral map and you
really looked at where it was going out
you would have said
let's find somebody with these criteria
but and let's find florida and remember
one of the last candidates considered
was that police chief in orlando
remember her
african-american woman chief in orlando
stellar record tough on crime you know
if you're looking to do the classic okay
i need the vp to help me in the in the
voting booth that's the direction you
would have gone but
he ended up with this
yeah he's just begun three more years
enjoy whose laugh was about this
was that really your life why was that
no
we have wait i was trying to do it hey i
was just chatting
about it can you do her french accent
like she was doing in paris oh my that
was
and that's
i mean how stupid does she think people
are
don't say that about your vice president
tom please it's going to upset uh
native americans so so so let's let's
look at this on what happened this
insider story here is the last one that
we'll do
across racial lines policing emerged as
a deciding factor in the election this
is an inside the insider story from
albany to cleveland ballots measure most
of which centered on the amount of
police presence particular areas should
have
had varying degrees of success in
minneapolis for example for example
voters had to decide whether to replace
the city's police department with a
department of public safety that would
employ a comprehensive public health
approach to ensure the community's
welfare right
uh
the ballot measure which was prompted by
george floyd's
murder was rejected by about 60
minneapolis voters but cleveland
ballot uh measure fared much differently
94 ohio city's voters were in favor of
instituting an amendment to create a
civilian
led board and community police
commission that would have final same
police uh policies and discipline as
these and other states show policing
took the forefront uh during the latest
batch of elections look this whole thing
about defunding the police how big it
got it's always about defunding your
police it's not about defunding my
police but i want you to defund your
police because in our area let's keep
the cops in your area let's not keep the
cops there's a lot of hypocrisy there so
do you think the same thing is going to
play a big role in 2024 2023 when the
next election comes around i don't think
so okay because i think people are smart
enough to know that this is complete bs
i mean this this
it was a perfect storm for something
like this to happen last year and it
happened the pandemic george floyd all
these things led to this reaction
there's no way people ultimately want
this and i think it's going to fade away
to bigger topics i really do i think you
know police departments need some reform
in some cities minneapolis clearly
needed a little reform but you just
don't throw the police away like this
and i don't think it's going to be a hot
button issue in 2024 tom i thought that
the the cleveland measure was
the citizens being sensible because what
did they say they didn't say defund the
police in cleveland they said let's get
a commission
that is not beholden remember police
internal affairs is investigating itself
there's always there's always been a a
corrupt lien there and so i thought that
this people of cleveland were being very
very prudent saying hey let's get an
independent commission so that when we
have internal affairs we have you know
you know questionable shootings and
things like this that happen let's have
somebody else in the room to make sure
that we that we hold the police
accountable and we do things sensibly
and so i love what i love that measure
in cleveland and then in minneapolis i
think what you said to open this little
segment you're absolutely correct defund
your police not my police yeah by the
way this thursday is going to be
thursday riots i don't know if you guys
are ready or not this thursday is going
to be thursday right day because that is
when the verdict comes on verdict comes
so people have to be ready
on standby oh they have they have to
because if this comes out then a lot of
things are showing that he's going to
come out innocent
if it does it's on they're going to need
a lot of police in certain areas but
interesting part though is how's that
going to play out now that trump's not
that the helm and and because he was the
one that was blamed for everything even
though there's governors below that this
than the other so how's that now going
to reflect on biden then of is that is
that cool is that okay
is everything going to go away um so
that's going to be interesting to see
yeah so look here's a couple things as
we're wrapping up i want to give you a
couple updates number one i want to give
you a mafia states of america update
okay for people that are still following
that story fyi if you haven't seen
gerard on the podcast for the last
couple weeks except for the 101 is
because he has one assignment and he's
working with eric and the team to finish
up mafia states of america and they're
doing a fantastic job
i'm proud of the crew the products
looking amazing i cannot wait to release
it to you i will tell you
this is not going to be on youtube
everybody needs to know it is not going
to be on youtube the only thing you will
see on youtube is a number of short
clips that will be shared because it is
10 episodes and we had a crew of i don't
know 40 people working on this project
this ended up being a half a million
plus of a project it'll be sold the 10
episodes you can either be able to buy
one of them we haven't decided what the
price gonna be per episode maybe it's
9.99 and you buy the whole thing for
49.99 so stay tuned there will be a
website we will release we're getting
close to potential release like i told
sammy when he was on the podcast it's
either going to be end of the year
december or it's going to be 2022 and
what did sammy say let me just say this
it's gonna be the end of the year but
we're working on it to get it done for
you so hang tight with mafia states the
product looks
ridiculous this is all i'm gonna tell
you you're gonna flip on when you see
the product and second thing is kai
kai's been running vt merch we got a lot
of new products that's coming coming out
uh with valuetainment a lot of big
surprises coming out one of the things
that we had a very hard time with
because the the your next five moves is
selling out on amazon tremendously and
we had a call with uh uh what do you
call it with uh
simon schuster they now have it at
target it's selling all over the place
uh and the the ranking keeps going
higher and higher and higher with the
book and we're not even promoting it but
many of you ask for signed copies and we
only had a hundred and it sold out like
in a couple days we talked to simon
schuster we have another badge of a
hundred signed copies of your next five
moves if you don't have it and you'd
like one the link below is gonna give it
to you in the comments section go to vt
merch.comvtmerch.com
[Music]
the first hundred that order your next
five move signed it'll be sent over your
way but you got to go to vt merch and i
wouldn't be waiting if it's a gift you
want to get for somebody for christmas
uh my wife just texted me saying baby i
think you should do your next vibe move
for kids i'm like babe as if life is not
as busy as it is let's add another book
to the plate anyways uh thank you for
listening we're gonna do this again on
thursday our friend adam's going to be
back on thursday and i think who else do
we have on thursday somebody else's
danielle as well okay danielle's going
to be with us on this thursday so do not
miss this thursday's podcast take
everybody bye-bye bye-bye
you